i get up at crazy hours whether it's  three o'clock in the morning by the way  when we were talking in london i was  getting up at three because i had to be  on set by four  i'm sorry by seven so whatever time my  call time is  and i tell this to studios and directors  and our producers whatever time i call  time so my call time is at  seven then you back your clock up four  hours and then that's when i get up  and train twice i'll get my cardio in  and breakfast and then i'll go  hit the weights clanging and banging we  call it  jack and iron but like what time do you  go to bed i mean you might shoot really  late at night  i'm averaging on a movie on average  probably about five hours of sleep